hey 42 here in large quantities raw
cashew nuts can be fatal
they contain a toxic call to yura shop
even cashew nuts sold as raw cashews in
the supermarket's have been steamed to
remove the dangerous chemical but cashew
nuts are child's play some food can kill
you with a single bite even when cooked
fugu is a luxurious fish nut popular in
Japan what eating it is a huge gamble
the intestines ovaries and liver of the
fugu fish contain a poison called
tetrodotoxin that is 12,000 times
deadlier than cyanide it's so lethal at
a dose smaller than the head of a pin is
enough to kill you and the single fish
contains enough poison to kill 30 people
dine is unfortunate enough to ingest a
poison will experience paralysis then
rapid death there is no antidote because
of the risks involved Japanese chefs
must undergo two to three years of
intense training then pass an exam
before they can obtain a license to
prepare fugu fish because of the
expertise involved the fugu dish can
usually cost around $200 the hope will
Apple can be deceivingly dangerous an
apple seeds contain a type of cyanide or
beer some very small amounts the
quantity of apple seeds one would need
to ingest you suffer a lethal reaction
is huge but by no means impossible you
should also watch out for cherry peach
and apricot pips as they all contain the
same poisonous cyanide compound nutmeg
is a spice commonly used around
Christmas but it's also a hallucinogenic
yes you can actually trip on nutmeg
however eating just five point five
grams of nutmeg can lead to convulsions
and eight point five grams can lead to
seizures eating a whole nutmeg leads to
a condition known as chronic nutmeg
psychosis which includes severe vomiting
paranoia and
the sense of impending doom another food
that can send you off the rails is tuna
tuna is known to absorb mercury and once
it's in your body it can travel to your
brain and drive you insane whilst it's
unlikely that eating the large amount of
tuna will kill you it's a good idea to
monitor your weekly intake
however FDA recommendation states that
small children and pregnant women should
avoid tuna altogether Jamaica is home to
one of the most dangerous fruits on the
planet the ackee fruit is jamaica's
national fruit however it contains a
poison called hypoglycemia properly
eaten can cause what's been called the
Jamaican vomiting sickness I'm sure you
can guess what symptoms are involved but
the poison can also cause comas and
death when the fruit is unripe it is
riddled with the poison so you must wait
until the ackee fruit part turns red and
opens naturally once open the only
edible portion is the yellow are really
which surrounds the poisonous black
seeds to make his national dish is acai
with salt fish cassava is a woody
vegetable native to South America but
it's more commonly known to Americans as
tapioca the roots and leaves of the
plant contain yep you guessed it cyanide
cassava must be prepared in a very
particular way to avoid any toxins you
would think hotdogs are completely
innocent you won't find any cyanide here
but two small children they're one of
the most dangerous foods available
hotdogs are the single biggest choking
threat among small children of any food
hotdogs account for 17% of all
food-related of fixations among children
younger than 10 years of age and can
often be fatal in South Korea a popular
delicacy is sanic aji or raw baby
octopus to prepare the dish the octopus
is dismembered seasoned with sesame oil
and then served immediately because of
the hasty preparation many of the
tentacles will still be moving
round whilst you eat it each tentacle of
an octopus has its own brain so if you
swallow its whole
it won't hesitate to use it suckers on
your throat if you don't chew it
properly before swallowing it can use it
suckers to affix itself to the inside of
your throat and choke you to death
Nambiar in southern Africa is home to a
strange delicacy giant bullfrogs are a
highly sought-after food in Nambiar but
there's a reason the French stick to
eating the legs only the organs and
skins of most frogs contain toxins the
giant bullfrog is riddled with a deadly
toxin that causes OSHA ketut a cup or
more simply ports temporary kidney
failure which can cause death if
immediate medical attention is not
sought the giant bullfrog is considered
safe if harvested and eaten after
molting season or the fur drain when
their levels of toxins have mellowed out
but the biggest cause of food-related
death in the world is the simple chicken
uncooked chicken and other raw meats can
contain Salmonella bacteria which can be
fatal and people of weaker immune
systems in the US alone poultry is
responsible for 20% of food-related
deaths
thanks for the view subscribe for more
thoughty2